[Music]
basketballs not something I wanted to be
great at but I guess that's what God
wanted it's your friend Sarah Silverman
we are at the YMCA which stands for
Young Men's Christian Association never
a pro aspirations not really oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] just love dominating I have a lot
of tricks and that may sound like a
Globetrotters move actually I'm a
Washington Generals fan I feel like this
year is their year go through oh just
kidding hey let me just give you some
pointers you know when you're dribbling
you shouldn't even have to look at the
ball you're not looking to fall at all
you're just dribbling you're dribbling
and then BOOM you're playing with the
legend but she's like a legend for being
one of the worst teammates ever
[Applause]
trash-talking is is so important
[Music]
I learned it from my dad I think all
bullies learn to be bullies from their
dads well thank you smell like eggs I'm
vegan they don't even eat eggs I don't
know why I would smell like them I think
I have like a good amount of
testosterone because I have a lot of
unwanted hair and it's like you want to
put on some work we're shooting in here
stop exercising show business is
happening me it's a place to really
channel all of my rage [ __ ]
it's fun it's really fun so what happens
when you got skills you'll get a vagina
in your pants you just really don't ever
want to meet your idols or even someone
that you just think is mildly funny I
think you really needed that
she's just an example of the worst
person to ever become which spiritually
intellectually emotionally sorry how
much screen time does she need she need
like a ladder yeah
[Music]
well come in just for a second guys I
think it's so great like you're
challenging me a little bit but like you
know this is a video that's basically
about me you need to like pull back and
just really like be like whoa she got me
a little bit more she always picks me to
be on her team because I'm black my
percentages are better when you play
black basketball players she told me
that I think of it as I'm helping people
and I'm helping myself by treating
others as less than
[Music]
this game we lost my point unless we do
a sudden-death right now which is if I
make this shot and I made it
oh so looking good I need to look 36 I'm
not [ __ ] kidding
white diamonds filter